and when that chess match plays out
coach as the Chiefs have the football
it'll be at some level between offensive
coordinator Eric be enemy of the Chiefs
defense coordinator Robert Salah of the
49ers a pair of minority candidates who
had interviews this year in the coaching
cycle neither got offers neither could
have been hired until after their
season's end but nobody decided to wait
for them like we've seen coaches get
waited for in the past as their team to
get to the Super Bowl and that leads me
to the main reason I want to talk to you
today you wrote an excellent column that
appeared over the weekend on pft about
the importance of evolving the Rooney
rule and I want to start where the
Rooney rule started a generation ago
your understanding coach of what it was
intended to do when the owners put in
place a mechanism requiring every team
to interview at least one minority
candidate for every head coaching
vacancy yeah and what happened and it
was a similar situation to what we have
now a couple years the minority hiring
seems to slow down there were a couple
of guys who seem to be good candidates
but because of playoffs or whatever it
just didn't seem to be working and they
the NFL got together and had a committee
and what can we do and people shouldn't
look at that as a negative the purpose
of the committee was what can we do to
help what can we do to help owners be
able to see the field a little clearer
see maybe people that they wouldn't be
focused on and Dan Rooney was a big part
of it and Dan Rooney has been
instrumental in a lot of things from
labor negotiations to scheduling to
doing different things to helping out
and he you know suggested that and he
suggested it as a way to help the
process and get people to slow down the
process and look other places look under
the rocks a little bit and investigate
and that's all it was designed to do and
people kind of look at it now as well as
the quota
making people interview certain people
and that I don't think that was ever Dan
thought his thought was well if you know
what you're looking for if you have a
blueprint and you can get more people
into consideration you can look at more
people you're going to end up making a
better decision whether that's hiring a
minority coach or not you're going to
get the best person for you and that's
what it's all about
and as I said in a column that's exactly
how he found my comment and I remember
it because we were preparing for the
Super Bowl and Dan called me and he said
you know I've got some really good
people on my staff Bill Cowher had just
retired and he had Dick LeBeau and Russ
Grimm and Ken Whisenhunt so he had some
quality quality candidate but he said
you know his father's always looking for
younger defensive coaches good
communicators and he had interviewed
this guy by the name of Mike Thomas
someone has recommended him to him and
he came away really impressed
Mike was 33 at the time had only been a
defensive coordinator for one year in
Minnesota but they struck it off
dan talked to him a couple times did a
couple of re interviews and ended up
saying this is a guy for us but it was
slowing down the process who was working
outside of his normal situation of who
he would look at and trying to
investigate the whole landscape and it
ended up being good for him and good for
the Steelers and good for the league so
that's what the jist of it was and I
don't think now people look at it that
way people are looking at it as it's
something I have to do so I'm gonna get
it over as quick as I can
and coach you throughout some of the
buzz words that we hear from people who
criticize the rule or opponents of it
from quotas to mandatory interviews and
the suggestion that you must hire a
minority coach I just think that hiding
in plain sight is this disparity
regardless of the industry when the
workers are 70% plus african-american
and the managers are a ridiculously
small percentage
and they are managing a workforce that a
lot of them were once in it just it's
something something's not right here
there's something wrong and I don't know
that we can boil down to what the root
cause of it is but the bottom line is I
feel like and we've had this discussion
before owners decide who they're gonna
hire before they even start the
interview process and the Rooney rule is
aimed at as you said getting owners to
tap the brakes take a broader view
expand their horizons consider other
opportunities and other candidates
before making that decision instead of
making the decision before you just go
through a perfunctory interview process
right and and that is I think the
biggest thing that could help a whole
process I know I've talked to owners
I've had people you know ask me about
certain candidates and it's I had guys I
could recommend and my first question is
always well what are you looking for and
oftentimes the owner doesn't know just
tell me who's good who's smart out there
well what you want you want an offensive
coach do you want a defensive coach you
want somebody just to coach the
quarterbacks just to call the plays you
want a leader you want a younger guy do
you want an older guy you want someone
who's been a head coach before those are
all things that need to be thought
through and then once you decide then
you can look at the landscape and say
that's what I want
you mentioned Eric venema and Robert
Solow you know everybody's looking for
that person to speak into the
quarterback and call the plays but these
two guys are exceptional hitters you can
tell that from the way their teams play
and you know not every successful head
coach is the guy who groomed perfect I
think Bill Belichick has won a lot of
Super Bowl he can come up as a
quarterback coach Pete Carroll has been
in Super Bowl done a tremendous job and
they've got productive often but it is
we've got to get I think past the notion
that only certain characteristic so
we've got to just coach the quarterback
and to me that's the biggest thing slow
down the process find out who the
beaters are and
a good leader is going to take you a
long way the title of your column is
it's time to evolve the Rooney rule what
specifically do you think the NFL should
do at this point to evolve it there's
been suggestions about finding ways to
enhance the pipelines specifically on
the offensive side of the ball
quarterbacks coaches offensive
coordinators what would you recommend at
this point that the league adopt for all
32 teams who are filling these key
vacancies I think there's got to be some
emphasis in the league office on
creating I don't know what you'd call it
rosters a list of guys for the owners
before they get into the process right
now some people use search firms they
use headhunters there's internet
searches there's all kinds of things
analytics and so it's not necessarily
the interview process and I said it you
know my last out I didn't have an
immersive Jim Irsay knew about me we
talked about things on the phone I think
you're right he had his mind made up
that I was a guy he wanted before an
interview process even started so I
think that the idea of the Rooney rule
the spirit of what the incident was good
but I don't think it happens that way
now very few times as an owner say hey
I'm going to do six interviews and then
I'm going to decide between these six
guys so somehow you've got to get
information to them and they've got to
get to know some of these guys before
that in a butte process Petersen is a
great example Doug Peterson I did a
story for NBC when we had them in the
Superbowl in five years before the Super
Bowl he's coaching high school ball in
Louisiana but the thing about it Jeffrey
Lurie knew him knew who he was about the
leadership moving from Andy Reed and so
he was able to hire him when a lot of
people you know oh this guy doesn't have
a most experience I think Michael and
Barty said where's prepared or you know
not ready to go
where's qualified hire in a long time
the owner knew a little bit more about
him the resume and to me that's what's
got to happen if we're going to help the
league utilize everybody and find that
Robert Salas and Eric the enemies can be
very good head coaches the first branch
of the Doug Peterson coaching tree is
Frank Reich who was hired by the Colts
after the Super Bowl when the Josh
McDaniels hire fell through and that
leads me to my next point coach Peter
King has suggested more from the
standpoint of fairness to the teams that
are playing in the postseason this
process goes so quickly he suggested
delaying the entire hiring cycle
interviews and everything until after
the Super Bowl do you think something
like that would have an incidental
benefit in getting the owners to take
that broader scope they've got weeks to
map out who all they're going to talk to
before they can even begin talking to
anyone would it delay until after the
Super Bowl maybe enhance the
opportunities for minority candidates
well it would help the entire process
and I think it would help make better
decisions because these owners do now
they feel under pressure to get their
first choice to get the guy before
someone else
I think the Giants ownership said that
before we we felt like we were going to
lose this guy - I think it was
Mississippi State
but everybody's under the fear that
better act fast I won't get the first
choice and if I don't get my first
choice I'll be seen as a failure in this
process and again that was Dan Rooney's
mo and you know I always go back to that
if you model yourself after success you
have a chance to be successful Dan hired
three coaches in 50 years all the
coaches were successful all of them went
specifical and he hired them all he
hired Chuck Noll after they lost Super
Bowl three the Baltimore Colts lost
Super Bowl three to the New York Jets
he hired Bill Cowher late in the process
I was on the staff with Bill in Kansas
City when he got the job in Pittsburgh
in 1992 and Bill had 20 or four meetings
with the Rooney
he didn't know if he's going to get the
job and it was still well into January
before he got hired and the same thing
with Mike Tomlin we were comparing for
the Super Bowl game when then called me
and said I think I'm gonna hire this guy
but he took his time and he didn't care
if people thought oh you do not get in
the number one choice you're not moving
fast enough so I think slowing it down
would help and it would allow owners to
investigate poor people and make sure
they're making decisions we had this the
last three hiring cycle there's 20
changes two-thirds of the week in the
last three years so we're not doing this
right regardless of who were hiring
we're not doing this right when you're
having one year coaches and then they're
out two years and they're out obviously
we need to do something to fix it and
some have suggested coach that the
fundamental problem here is that there
aren't enough minority owners Schad Kahn
of the Jaguar is the only minority owner
of 32 teams and that if they're what and
it's not like you can just wave a wand
and have more minority owners you're
talking about a huge amount of wealth
that needs to be accumulated teams have
to be for sale but do you attribute in
any part the problem to the fact that
the demographics among ownership don't
reflect maybe the you know the
demographics among the players obviously
or at least what the league is trying to
get to as it relates to the coaches I
think the ownership really doesn't have
an understanding of what can be
successful who can be successful and
they they don't know people again I come
back to that I've talked to some owners
who I know have a a good heart they want
to do the right thing they want to be
successful they want to win and they
they don't have an idea of who to hire
they don't have an idea of who's good
and they take their cues from what they
read in the media what they see on the
internet and you know it's just I think
it's more information than anything else
and somehow we can help that process
there was a time when there were no
minority players and everybody
the league was in good shape in 1946 and
nobody was concerned and then Paul Brown
said you know what we can make this
league better I had better players on my
Massillon high school team that had
african-american players I had better
players at Ohio State when I had
minority players so if I want to win I
can do this a little bit better
and he brought african-american players
into the game there was a time when
there's no african-american quarterbacks
now we look at Patrick mahomes of the
Mark Jackson and the game is better and
it took a while for for people
understand that Charlie Ward won the
Heisman Trophy and didn't get dressed
Charlie Ward would have been Lamar
Jackson now so we have come past that
it's taken time and I don't think people
don't want to have minority coaches or
minority quarterbacks or ignored
anything else but they don't always know
and getting information I think is the
biggest help and that's what the Rooney
rule was supposed to be trying to do I
think we've got to do it in some
different ways now and you make a great
point when we look at the turnover and I
was actually surprised only five coaches
were fired during and after the 2019
season because I'm so used to almost 25%
per year
and at some point the owners have to
realize we are doing this wrong
something's not right here if we're
turning over we had a montage last week
of the Browns press conferences for the
past eight years every time they said
they got the right guy for the job they
said every other year they get the right
guy for the job and they never get the
right guy for the job
and that is the issue and you know to me
I think they've looked at the wrong
formula because just about everybody
they've hired has been that a
quarterback whisperer somehow we've got
to get the quarterback going and you
know it's leadership that's what wins
one you got to find good leaders good
leaders can hire people to train the
quarterback and and that's what we've
got to come up with and find out who
computers are and they can come from
offense from defense in any position yes
joe-joe special thing john harbaugh has
proven it and i remember when i was he
knew some hired John Harbaugh and he
just that was a guy he wanted and he
felt like he was a lot like Nick Saban
he had a lot of the qualities that Nick
had I was it worked with Nick Saban he
wants the conferral process and who said
John Harbaugh is the leader that I want
and to me that that's what we've got to
get to you mentioned that the media has
a role in crafting those lists and you
know it's easier said than done because
when you're in the middle of football
season there's a lot of things that are
happening but coach you've got the voice
I've got the platform and I think next
season we really do need to try to shine
a light as early as we can on all the
names regardless of background
regardless of race regardless of
anything all the names that are out
there so that the owners when they're
thinking sometime around Halloween I may
have to make a change right around New
Year's Day get the names out there get
them thinking about more guys get them
doing the research instead of narrowing
down on one or two or three guys and
having that process rocket through so
quickly yep
III agree I think that that is critical
and as we talk about guys whose units
have done very well and who are making
progress
I mean you saw that with Robert Sala
during the year how well they were
playing and it's how excited this group
was and how much energy they were
playing with and I know I thought and
something is going on there and yeah
they've got young talent and it's great
but somebody's molding that group and we
do we talk about that more no question
about it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports